I just want to meet a guy that I like as
much as you is that too much to ask I
hate everyone but you I got a cake mix I
got a bottle of scotch and a really
weird jewelry making kit so what are we
doing first
where's your girlfriend
she's not my girlfriend please she will
be she's hot and she worships you
we have a reservation guys I have to do
everything pick the restaurant
make the reservation wonder why those
relationships didn't last too mature for
this now they'd spend the whole weekend
roasting a chicken together hey you know
that you posted on Instagram wake up
you've been replaced hey chin ditch me
don't send your kids to private school
all kids that go to private school turn
into conservative douchebags Tim went to
private school right and I am a douche
bag
tamanna I got engaged oh my god it's
gonna hard to stay in the moment when
your partner keeps telling you that
everything she's doing is her signature
move Sasha my signature move
I don't dim it you went out with like
three girls recently they live at home
you told him a lot about me guess I
should have known that as soon as you
found someone else to couple up with
that you be done with me
yes I'm less available to you now than I
was when there was no one else in my
life you still talk to someone at 2:00
in the morning nothing changed for you
it just changed for me can you
acknowledge that please
[Music]
there looks much like a lesbian you are
a lesbian yeah but I don't wanna look
okay you're like offensive to yourself
okay they go
we're going anywhere still the only ones
who think we're funny
[Music]
you